samaras a parfois on est encore en ce
moment là ça génie des métiers j'ai peur
d'être attaqué ou est aujourd'hui j'ai
fait une rigolade je sais pas si je peux
vous la dire alors des six nations mais
je sais pas ce que vous voulez vous
qu'il courait s'il ya des jets pas nous
noté au menteur commente sa nounou est
proprement
non je sais pas si la salle non pas du
tout il faut le faire impunément
j'ai appelé toute la journée le cabinet
vous savez de docteur cohen jean michel
cohen était là hier et toute la journée
j'ai appelé donc son cabinet jeudi et
comme hier il a dit il à dire moment il
a dit on va éviter la pandémie
et moi je suis dit il faut que manger du
pain de mie lordon clichés ap sa
secrétaire toute la journée avec des
voies différentes je vous jure que c'est
vrai
jt oui est ce que c'est vrai qu'il veut
plus mangée par me après jean michel
cohen m'a appelé ben oui il ya plein de
gens qui appellent au cabinet
[Applaudissements]
j'ai demandé à tous mes potes l'appelez
pas pareil d'avis parce que c'est une
farce ou est-ce qu'il faut plus manger
de temps mais là elle à judy de
n'importe quelle marque plus jacques est
venu harris et donc la secrétaire allons
retrouver toute sa journée et donc il
m'a appelé après voilà je voulais je
vous le dis voilà donc briscous et de
tous types
alors s'il vous faut le casting des
chroniqueurs ne touche pas à mon pot
vous poserez parcouru la planète entière
a su trouver les meilleurs et puis
finalement vous avez pris une grande
décision choisir les moins chers c'est
vrai c'est pour ça que celui-là d'heure
pour moins cher ou des gens qui sont
venus à titre non lucratif exactement
mais vous avez quand même la chance
d'avoir des chroniqueurs quand chacun
des compétences extraordinaires à la
poule awards c'est vrai et c'est vrai
ils sont tous des super pouvoirs
vous allez lui voit pas trop où est l
entend pas de super et moi l'envers
succès lui pas bronzer à 150 mètres
d'une cabine à uv des super pouvoirs
pour cent et que séoul
mais on va le voir tout de suite parce
que pour le voir du meilleur chroniqueur
vous allez voir ça fait une très belle
introduction les nommer son bibi
benjamin castaldi qui non seulement
emploie une expression que personne ne
connaît mais qui en plus n'articule pas
benjamin gille b sur un court il est
très fort en mai sur un conte de même il
a une puissance il est quand même vélo
style et nassim el baile
[Rires]
isabelle morini bosc pour sa superbe
habitations du professeur tournesol
mes rapports avec 45 rit pas bêtement il
en a 28 pro gutto il faut quoi booter
votre film est il merci pour tout et
votre fils
pourquoi quoi
[Musique]
et jean michel maire pour sa mythique
diction qui fait que son orthophoniste
ne sera jamais au chômage avec on en
garde la pêche
et ça casse un peu des préjugés on sort
de là dedans avec le sourire aux lèvres
j'ai adoré ce film cruzeiro c'est ça le
jeu de 8 ans et géraldine pas compresser
ya stade il faut pas le voir vous
connaissez chez vous bien excusable mais
non mais vous le savez jamais revu kelly
tu connaissais même pas ça vous là bas
quelqu'un de venir à blida placo par
mois jean michel cohen peut-être
[Rires]
j'appelle jean michel cohen très très
bonne idée
c'est là pour ça la patte de suite et je
vais dire est annoncée une nouvelle
je veux dire faire le coup du pain de
mie à huy sa flamme à une belle en train
de manger des boulettes sur diététiciens
oui mais prend des boulettes à l'anis
oui oui jean michel mon chéri mon chéri
dis moi je t'appelle tu as bien dit hier
qu'il fallait pas manger du pain de mie
et tu fais que ça ferait si tu me
faisais ça hein on émission tél oui
c'est cindy mois on à l'antenne chaque
label
[Applaudissements]
jean michel sabbat ebay ce soit
l'antenne ça tabasse belle ou pas comme
ça mais on se tâte lyle
oui ça l'est jean michel au thème faire
sont aperçus en connaître personne que
frère sata balle chacun avait un
objectif dans l'émission c'est mettre en
valeur la barca et surtout la langue
française bien fait mais oui cette fois
à l'aide de phrases qui je pense sont
étudiés dans quelques années dans toutes
les universités du monde entier pour le
voir de la phrase la plus philosophique
les nommés sont
[Musique]
si la luna j'aime les fromages qui sont
tranquillement de son bouquet le caprice
des dieux et des planches on dirait mon
uc cyril hanouna jean-michel eric je ne
sais pas d'où vient votre haine mais
aujourd'hui devant les téléspectateurs
de tpm p j'ai besoin qu'on brise la
glace c'est beau ça cyril hanouna
quelle est la seule émission de télé
réalité qu'a animée faustine bollaert
est la mi mai une émission télé réalité
à laquelle je sais ce que c'était
c'était je me souviens pas boufbowl que
des pauvres
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est pas ça c'est pas ça de la part de
jean pour moi c'est le blog de toucher
un bogue le gars saoul sûr c'est un kiff
de toucher le bloc de glace chez vous su
que vous aviez envie de le toucher aussi
et votre cul cul aussi et peut-être
nominés mieux le bloc de glace
moi je fais ça le biogaz est plus frais
je passe entre ferrer comme phrase là
toi ça piquouse s'applique aux il faut
que je reste tout ça alors touche pas on
peut ce n'est pas seulement des débats
sur les césar et le cours d'un virus
c'est aussi des vannes il y en a partout
tout le temps alors bien sûr comme
chaque semaine j'en ai choisi trois pour
le war de la meilleure vannes
les nommés sont
jean michel maire qui n'arrive pas à
accepter qu'ils ne soient plus le sex
symbol de l'émission jean michel était
un peu le séducteur de l'équipe le beau
gosse de l'équipe etc
jean eric est arrivé eric avec son stand
sa culture sa prestance et c'est tout
d'un coup les ce qui fait joli ont
commencé à discuter avec lui et du coup
je me suis senti un peu chez cyril
hanouna qui prouve qu'il défendra
toujours la liberté d'expression est
d'ailleurs nabila quand elle fera son
retour à la télé elle refera chez nous
sa radio et elle ne viendra que chez
nous a dit voilà c'est qu'ici où elle
s'éclate
voilà donc nabila embrasse fort ma
chérie on verra nabila khédive et de
bedie qui a trouvé la meilleure
technique pour gagner prochainement à
questions pour un champion
l'année des cds karl lagerfeld 2020 2019
en visite en scooter
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors la meilleure bonne pour moi c'est
aujourd'hui
alors toujours en pause cartonne parce
qu'on a une famille est la particule de
notre famille c'est qu'on s'aime mais on
aime s'en mettre plein la gueule ça qui
est beau j'aime beaucoup cette tête
s'ils avaient pas ça en fait on se
ferait chier comme une soirée chez
stéphane bern alors pour le meilleur
tacle de la semaine les nommés sens
eric naulleau qui se demandent qui
déteste le plus
entre raquel garrido et jean michel
maire au final ce que ce soit vous
pouvez dire parce qu'on est pressé là on
a un valence ton poste important après
je vous le dis est ce que ce soir vous
le dire c'est une émission d'intello à
certains chroniqueurs
alors oui cyril hanouna qui hésitent
longue - vannes et philippe katerine et
qui finalement se dit ni kunuk alors la
coiffure comme ça je voulais les vosges
comme assuré mais moi j'ai des cheveux
tu les as donc sapiens frais comme ça
moi ça faisait des frisettes ici l'huile
à l'eau et date établie
c'était du boulot aussi à toi c'est du
boulot là titres et des boutons on les
voit pas mais plus tu es dans ta tombe
aux shoots a bear
ça fait un beau cheveux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et benjamin castaldi qui quand on lui
parle de son régime devient lyon enfin
un lionceau qui il a pris beaucoup de
muscles franchement il est magnifique
maintenant il faut qu'il sache un peu
donc jeunes il faut que tu cours
voilà à peu près une heure tous les
matins quand même il a gardé le musc il
va être jusqu'à deux heures ce matin le
long par le physique du tabac et bien
sûr parce qu'on mène devant des tacles
maintenant il est temps de voir ce qui
est encore plus fort que les césar et
moins chiant que les césars remettre le
trophée du thar baba musique de suspense
qui a le plus de tacles et qui sera
l'hôte rabat bien sûr alors qui a le
plus tacler ses collègues que cette
semaine qui ne peut s'empêcher de mettre
en boîte ses camarades série vous savez
comme une victoire devant grange et
jusqu'à présent eh bien on le sera dans
un instant
[Applaudissements]
le 32e temps là bas avant des comptes
vous avez gagné trente et une fois sur
30 et une ya pas de suspense à son fils
le 32e tabac de l'histoire ne touche pas
à mon poste est décerné à
[Applaudissements]
le beaucoup travaillé on a les preuves
on allait voir que j'aurais pu faire une
spéciale je veux voir une spéciale
isabelle morini-bosc 6 y aller allons-y
prouver
on fit spa sacem ou non j'aurais rêvé de
chasse pendant une galère j'aimerais par
la vie de ronald mcdonald alors dans un
instant vous avez une donnée trois
conseils pour éviter l'espionnage les
donner aux téléspectateurs ça on attend
ça avec impatience que là on est tous en
train de fibres et surtout isabelle
parce que oui il faut te du cap nuls
dans son tel faux scoop est souvent les
ondes de hbo a c'est très important
parce que les jeunes à l'adhésion de m
c'est une télécommande est peu chargé
[Rires]
d'éliminer dans le public alors ma patte
sur rtl
[Musique]
une réponse qui s'appelle m'a soufflé
les faire douter la belle a souffert
déjà c'est peut-être son dernier souffle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
usa et qui t'envoient des mots d'amour
le soir les petits mots des pièces f1
mais c'est vous à qui j'envoie des sms
personne à part isabelle mois non c'est
oui mais nous aussi on en envahissant
c'est vrai voilà qui est libre bien que
je t'envoie des petits sms isawi des
fois je me demande ce que ça cache
ah oui c'est vrai je raconte
téléspectateurs fois je reçois des sms
elle me dit mais c'est vraiment pour moi
à oui oui je suis dit tu dois être
trompé de destinataire non maintenant
j'avais envie de bouger le cul